C'est un petit peu trop sombre ici.
Tu vois? Non?
Ce cote la, c'est tres sombre.
Ich bin ein wenig ein Kontrollfreak.
Für mich ist das wichtig.
Deswegen liebe ich das Internet,
denn ich kann für mich selber
entscheiden.
Yeah, better.
Oh yeah, much better!
Yes. Now you can see me.
Like me. Click me. Buy me.
Die digitale Verführung.
Man muss einen
gesunden Menschenverstand haben,
wenn man herumsurft
und dort unterwegs ist.
Man muss wissen, dass Unternehmen
sehr interessiert sind
an allen Datenspuren,
die wir hinterlegen.
Diese können sie gezielt einsetzen,
um mich wieder mit personalisierter
Werbung anzusprechen.
* Popmusik *
# Who you are?
Ich bin Aldo Gnocchi. Ich bin 37.
Ich bin Unternehmer
im Bereich Digitales Marketing.
Ich doziere an Hochschulen wie
der Fachhochschule Nordwestschweiz.
* Popmusik *
Ich begebe mich heute
auf eine Customer Journey
und will mir einen Active-
Noise-Cancelling-Kopfhörer kaufen.
Aldos Kundenreise beginnt.
Phase 1: bewusst sein.
Da ich bald in die Ferien verreise
und im Flugzeug entspannen will.
* Popmusik *
Hallo, ich bin Xenia Tchoumi.
Ich arbeite als Instagram-,
Facebook-
und Soziale-Netzwerke-Expertin -
und als Influencerin.
Ich habe mehr als 1,5 Mio. Follower
auf Instagram.
Und ich habe - puh! - fast 6 Mio.
auf Facebook.
* Popmusik *
Ich habe Content kreiert
und mehr Content kreiert.
Und nie gestoppt. Mit viel Konstanz.
Ich hatte Glück, dass einige
grosse Pages auf Facebook
meinen Content verteilt haben.
Alles organisch?
- Ja, ja, 100 %.
Wenn ich eine Google-Suche starte,
passiert auf diesen Plattformen
relativ viel.
Ich gebe Keywords ein und diese
sind ein Trigger für Werbeanzeigen.
Das kann der Shopping-Feed sein,
der mir zum Keyword
passende Produkte anzeigt.
Wenn ich eine solche Plattform
besuche, wird getrackt,
dass mein Interesse da ist.
Wenn eine Kampagne läuft,
eine automatisierte,
kann man den ganzen Produktkatalog
dieser Onlineshops verknüpfen.
Mit den Plattformen Google,
Facebook usw.
kann man dann
gleich ein Remarketing machen.
Das ist dann, wenn ich im Internet
von diesen Produkten verfolgt werde.
Remarketing erinnert den Kunden,
dass er sich für ein Produkt
interessiert hat.
Besucht er eine Website,
erhält er ein Cookie.
Dieses wird
auf seinem Gerät gespeichert.
Surft er weiter, sieht er womöglich
Werbung von z.B. Kopfhörern.
So wird das Verhalten des Konsumenten
online verfolgt.
* Popmusik *
Von unseren Kunden kennen wir
grundsätzlich die Informationen,
die sie uns geben:
Postleitzahl und die Adresse.
Wir machen damit aber normalerweise
keine Marketingmassnahmen.
Spannender sind eigentlich die Ver-
haltensdaten bei uns im Onlineshop,
welche Kategorien ein Kunde besuchte
und welche Produkte er sich ansah.
Wir schauen uns
eine Gruppe von Kunden an,
die sich ähnlich verhält.
Wir versuchen, aus diesen Infor-
mationen gezielt das herauszufinden,
was in der nächsten Werbung
vorkommen sollte.
* Popmusik *
Influencer sind insofern
ein Teil der Customer Journey,
als dass sie
ein Bedürfnis wecken können.
Sie können inspirieren.
Sie können auf neue Produkte
aufmerksam machen.
Und da fängt die Customer Journey
eigentlich an.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin heute hier in Genf -
v.a. bei Moet & Chandon.
Diese Marken finden mich immer!
* Popmusik *
# All night long.
Wir sind hier,
um es zu geniessen, aber auch,
um Kontakte zu knüpfen -
als Influencer.
Hallo, meine Leute!
Ich spreche selten Deutsch.
Aber wir sind hier
mit dem Schweizer Fernsehen.
Oh, die Blumen stehen dir so gut!
- Ja, finde ich auch.
Ja.
Wir filmen an der Moet-Party.
Ca va?
Yeah.
- He's like: "Yeah."
"Yeah!"
Share, ready, steady, go!
Shared!
Instagram?
- Ja.
Jetzt sehen uns 7 Mio. Leute?
Und ich mit den Blumen?
- Ja, schön, oder?
Sagst du mir jetzt noch,
wie viel du verdienst?
Warum bist du so neugierig?
- Das ist mein Beruf.
Sicher ist es nur wegen des Berufs.
Was lässt ihr euch
das Engagement von Xenia kosten?
Na ja, das Engagement von Xenia ...
Da möchte ich nicht
darüber sprechen.
Das muss sie vielleicht sagen.
Ich kann ...
Sie wollte nichts dazu sagen.
- Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Aber ich kann vielleicht etwas
dazu sagen,
wie wir bei Moet Hennessy normaler-
weise mit Influencern umgehen:
Sie werden bei uns nicht bezahlt.
Wir bieten ihnen an,
zu Events zu kommen,
zu denen nicht jeder Zugang hat
und geben ihnen Goodies,
was in Richtung Exklusivität geht.
Ich glaube,
viele Leute verstehen nicht,
dass es bei einem Influencer
nicht nur darum geht,
Produkte zu bewerben. Ich würde
sagen, das sind vielleicht 30 %.
Der Rest ist die Beziehung,
die du mit deinen Followern hast,
was deine Message ist.
Das hat nichts
nur mit Verkaufen zu tun,
sonst wäre es zu dry
und du hättest nie Follower -
oder zu wenige.
Wie viele Posts
musst du für Moet machen?
Im Vertrag haben wir zwei.
Zwei für eine Zusammenarbeit,
für eine Periode.
Auf welchen Post oder welche Story
bist du besonders stolz?
Die von gestern
hat mir gut gefallen.
Aber alles, auf das die Leute
eine positive Reaktion zeigen,
macht mich immer stolz.
Hi, guys!
I've been thinking
of using Instagram
to just speak to you
in a spontaneous way.
Try to focus on that one thing
that makes you happy
instead of the ten, twenty things
that make you feel sad!
And try to think about it
and make it bigger in your head!
It's kind of a trick
I start to learn
and it's working magic on my life.
So I wanted to share it with you -
like this, spontaneously.
Have a good day!
Ich glaube,
soziale Netzwerke sind ...
Auch wenn du 100 Follower hast:
Sie geben dir diesen immediate ...
... Dopamin-Hit.
Du hast ein schönes Foto
und postest es.
Es gibt sofort eine Reaktion.
Es ist wie, ja, ein bisschen
eine Droge, würde ich sagen.
Für mich ist das ...
Ich habe kein Problem.
Ich kann das kontrollieren
und verstehen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Ja, wir haben
eine erste Recherche auf Google
zu diesen Kopfhörern gemacht.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
wie die Customer Journey weitergeht.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
So bei 42 °C
ist das ein Riesenspass!
Da ich weiss,
dass manche meiner Freunde
solche Kopfhörer benutzen,
habe ich mir
eine Auswahl von Menschen gemacht,
von denen ich finde, sie könnten mir
ihre Erfahrung teilen.
Es werden aber ziemlich sicher
noch weitere darauf einsteigen.
Wie und wo überall versuchen Sie,
Ihre Kunden online zu erreichen?
Wir versuchen,
unsere Kunden auf allen Plattformen
und Platzierungen zu erreichen,
die irgendwie möglich sind.
Letztlich
muss unsere Werbung dort laufen,
wo sich der Kunde aufhält.
Das mag im einen Fall
ein Mobile Device sein -
vielleicht ein Feed auf Instagram
oder Facebook,
vielleicht ein Display-Ad
auf einer Newsplattform.
Unsere Werbemassnahmen
haben immer zum Ziel,
dass wir dem Kunden
nichts verkaufen, was er nicht will.
Den Entscheid, etwas zu kaufen,
fällt der Kunde ja immer am Schluss.
Und es gehört
ein Check-out-Prozess dazu.
Also sogar ich, der sagt,
er sei resistent,
weil er die Mechanismen versteht,
auch ich merke nachher:
"Okay, jetzt hat es wirklich
einen Einfluss."
"Jetzt ist es in meinem Kopf drin.
Jetzt rattert es."
Jedes Mal, wenn ich wieder
einen solchen Trigger sehe,
ein schönes Bild auf Instagram
oder auf Facebook oder wo ich bin,
befasse ich mich mit diesem Produkt.
Obwohl ich es nicht brauche,
kaufe ich es vielleicht.
* Popmusik *
Das waren die Onlineshops mit dem
grössten Umsatz in der Schweiz 2018:
amazon.de mit 660 Mio. Fr.
zalando.ch mit 785 Mio. Fr.
Digitec Galaxus mit 950 Mio. Fr.
Wie viel Prozent mehr Umsatz
machen Sie an einem Black Friday?
Genaue Zahlen
geben wir nicht heraus.
Was wir grundsätzlich
zum Black Friday sagen können,
ist,
dass es uns jedes Jahr überrascht,
wie viele Konsumenten
auf diesen Tag anspringen.
Aber ist es doppelt so viel?
Oder 30 % mehr?
Verglichen mit einem normalen Tag
ist es deutlich mehr
als doppelt so viel.
Jedes Unternehmen mit
kommerziellem Interesse versucht,
den Kunden zu erreichen.
In diesem Markt
werden Milliarden umgesetzt.
Auch wir versuchen,
mit digitalen Lösungen
auf eine personalisierte Art
den Kunden zu erreichen.
Retargeting ist
ein sinnvolles Mittel, glaube ich.
Wenn sich der Kunde etwas angeschaut
und noch keinen Kaufabschluss
gemacht hat,
ist es gut, ihn auf anderen Wegen
nochmals aufs Angebot zu bringen.
Aber wenn Sie das machen
und den Kunden daran erinnern,
dass er dieses Produkt kaufen soll
oder ihm noch ein anderes Produkt
in einer anderen Farbe zeigen,
verführen Sie ihn ja schon.
Wenn man das
"verführen" nennen möchte,
stimme ich diesem Statement
vollständig zu.
Ich würde es positiver formulieren
und es "Marketing" nennen.
Heute bin ich bei Visilab,
meinem Sponsor.
Ich bin schon lange nicht mehr
hier gewesen.
Es ist mein erstes Mal
in dieser Boutique.
Ich werde mir Brillen
für mich selbst ansehen,
denn ich habe viele Brillen
und liebe sie.
Ich bin selfmade und ich will,
dass die Leute das auch verstehen.
Ich bin z.B. Botschafterin
für die UN,
für SDG Goal for Gender Equality.
Mein Wirtschaftsstudium hilft mir
sicher bei einem Teil von dem,
was ich mache,
denn es gibt mehrere Themen.
Es ist ein Business.
Lebst du zu 100 % von dem?
- Ja, 100 %.
Und ich bin super zufrieden.
Ich würde das nicht ändern.
Wirst du das posten?
Auf Stories sicher, ja.
Zu 100 %.
Warum ist es schön?
Es zeigt die Geschichte,
wo ich bin, was ich mache,
und die Brille.
Diese Sonnenbrille gefällt mir
sehr gut. Es ist mein Stil.
Kaufst du sie?
- Wahrscheinlich.
Ich muss überlegen,
denn sie sind ziemlich teuer,
aber ich bin schon verliebt.
Du verdienst ja gutes Geld.
Du kannst es dir leisten, oder?
Ja, aber ich habe in meinem Leben
auch Spesen.
Es ist nicht nur den ganzen Tag
Shopping.
Die Zukunft dieses Marktes
kann wirklich
unglaubliche Science-Fiction werden.
Es gibt schon Avatars von Leuten,
die digital kreiert wurden.
Wird es irgendwann
einen Avatar von Xenia geben,
dem man folgen kann?
Gute Frage. Ich weiss es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Mittlerweile sind schon ziemlich
viele Empfehlungen reingekommen.
Interessant ist, dass Bose und Sony
das Rennen machen.
Aufpassen! Da kommt Verkehr!
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Wir haben zwei Noise-Cancelling-
Kopfhörer im Angebot.
Beide kosten 329 Fr.
Gemäss diesem Review müsste man sich
eigentlich für Sony entscheiden:
USB-C-Anschluss, besserer Sound ...
Ich würde sagen,
Sony hat die Nase vorn.
Zwei Minuten und zehn Sekunden -
aber du kamst auf den Punkt.
Also gut!
- Eine Frage, Aurel.
Ja?
Ist es dein Ziel, dass die
Konsumenten möglichst beide kaufen?
Oder ist es dein Ziel,
eine klare Empfehlung abzugeben?
Wenn ich eine klare Empfehlung habe,
gebe ich eine ab,
aber ich habe keine.
Uns ist es am Ende des Tages egal,
welches Produkt die Kunden kaufen.
Beide sind gut.
Aufgrund des Brands würde ich
wahrscheinlich Bose nehmen -
auch, wenn sie technisch gesehen
schlechter wären.
Ja, jetzt schauen wir mal,
wo sie am günstigsten sind
und wo ich sie bekomme.
Ah! So interessant!
Das ist jetzt Werbung mit Kopfhörern
von Media Markt.
Anscheinend weiss Facebook jetzt,
dass sich ein User
gerade Kopfhörer ansieht.
Wir erheben relativ genau, wie viele
Kundenkontakte sinnvoll sind,
bis es zu einer Bestellung kommt,
und welche zusätzlichen Kontakte
nichts mehr bringen.
Wir versuchen,
die Kampagne dort zu stoppen,
wo es keine Bestellungen mehr gibt.
Der Kunde
hat während der Customer Journey
zwischen zehn und 20 Kontakte
mit dem Produkt - sog. Touchpoints.
Wie viele Touchpoints
hast du gebraucht?
Ich würde sagen, es waren etwa zehn.
Aber ich war in diesem Bereich
nicht ganz unerfahren.
Du versuchst immer, eine
Dissonanzverminderung hinzukriegen,
indem du dir eben einredest,
wieso es doch eine gute Idee war,
das Geld auszugeben.
Das machen Konsumenten unbewusst -
immer.
Und jetzt am Schluss
fragte ich nochmals den Verkäufer
und er fand:
"Weisst du was?
Viele Sachen sprechen für Sony."
"Es gibt
keinen grossen Unterschied."
Auch seine Arbeitskollegen
sagen genau dasselbe.
Ich wollte es nicht zulassen.
Ich war beratungsresistent,
dadurch, dass ich dogmatischer Fan
der Marke Bose bin.
# Who you are?
Schlussendlich
habe ich kein grosses Risiko.
Wenn es nichts ist, kann man innert
14 Tagen vom Kauf zurücktreten.